So today, I want to explore the
problem that we face,
which is much more than a
dilemma, it's a quad-lemma in a
way,
or a quint-lemma of how we
manage our future energy demands
and how we invest our resources
in alternative forms of energy.
And I'm going to spend most of
this session talking about the
possibilities and limitations of
nuclear power.
And this will provide a
foundation for the lecture on
next Tuesday,
which will be particularly
directed at wind,
but more broadly at renewables.
So first, I'd like to have you
consider the distribution of
nuclear power plants in the
world and really reflect on
where they're not located,
and their high concentration,
particularly in the Eastern,
Midwestern part of the United
States,
but also in Europe.
So within the U.S.
you see that they're really
concentrated up in the
Northeast, but also south in
nearby Chicago.
And California is quite
striking in that in 1976 the
State of California enacted a
moratorium against new nuclear
power plant development.
If you look more closely at
Europe,
and particularly at France,
you can see a very high
dependence in some nations in
the European Union on nuclear
power.
France now receives
approximately seventy-five
percent of its power from
nuclear plants.
And inside the United States,
also there's quite a bit of
variability in reliance on
nuclear.
So in Connecticut,
for example,
nearly sixty-five percent of
the power that we consume in the
state comes from nuclear plants
in Niantic,
which is about forty-five miles
to the east of us on the Thames
River from the Millstone nuclear
power plants.
So it's quite curious how
different parts of the country,
different economies,
have treated nuclear power.
And explaining the cultural
predisposition to accept the
risks and accept the costs is
not an easy thing to do.
So just so you have an overview
of the status of the nuclear
industry in the world,
there are about 436 different
reactors that are operating in
thirty different countries.
Fifty reactors are now under
construction,
mostly in Asian nations.
And within the U.S.,
there are proposals for twenty
new reactors.
And of these,
four to eight may be online in
2020.
China has eleven online at
present, with twenty-two under
construction,
and is the nation where nuclear
development is most rapid in the
world.
Within the U.S.,
the operating licenses that
have had limits placed on them
of operating licenses between
thirty and forty years,
most of these are going to be
granted operating extensions.
And the concern was that the
plant or the infrastructure
would not have the capability of
lasting longer than forty years
at the outside.
But they're finding that the
engineering integrity of many of
the plants is higher than they
thought it might be.
But this basically is a
short-term lease on the problem
of decommissioning these nuclear
plants and also what we'll be
talking about in a few moments,
which will be the problem of
managing nuclear waste.
The MIT report,
the faculty report that was
issued in 2003 and then recently
updated that we asked you to
read has some really I think
important lessons and
conclusions embedded within it.
So they concluded that after
five years from 2003,
so this is two years ago,
no new plants are under
construction in the United
States,
and insufficient progress has
been made on waste management.
The sober warning is that if
more is not done,
nuclear power will diminish as
a practical and timely option
for climate change risk
mitigation.
So as one thinks about what are
options are,
particularly coal,
as opposed to investments in
renewables,
nuclear power,
one might think about it as a
problem of relative cost.
But you also might think about
relative risk and ease of
bringing additional capacity
online given the different
sources.
And underlying this,
I think, is an underestimated
cultural factor,
which is what we worry about in
the United States,
and our predisposition to
remember not just Chernobyl,
but also what happened at Three
Mile Island in 1979.
The capital costs of
constructing a new plant are
often enormous.
And because so much can go
wrong, including construction
delays that can cause interest
rates to rise and the amount
that has to be paid back to
investors to rise,
it's caused what's thought of
as a risks premium being put on
an investment funds.
So banks or private investment
companies often will loan the
money to a utility company that
wants to build a new plant,
but they will do so at a higher
rate when it's measured by
kilowatt hour.
And so there's about a two cent
per kilowatt hour difference
between nuclear compared to coal
and natural gas,
which makes this a very,
very expensive proposition.
Basically, the money costs more.
The legal and regulatory
structure that surrounds nuclear
power is rather complex.
The initial statute that
governed what now exists was the
Atomic Energy Act back in 1954
that we discussed a bit during
the beginning of the term when
we were talking about
atmospheric weapons testing.
But now, recall that the
technology,
that the science and
engineering foundation for
nuclear power plants,
really evolved out of the
nuclear weapons development
program.
So many of the nuclear power
plants that were the earliest
versions,
say at Hanford or at Oakridge
in Tennessee,
these plants were first
generation,
but they were designed
predominantly to provide
enriched fuel for atomic
weapons.
This defines both state and
federal authority concerning
nuclear energy.
And it really was the watershed
that ended the monopoly,
the government monopoly on
nuclear technology.
And it gave the private sector
a role in nuclear development,
and expressly prohibited states
from any role in transfer,
delivery, receipt,
acquisition,
possession,
or use of nuclear materials.
And it also gave the Atomic
Energy Commission the exclusive
authority to manage these
issues.
What is interesting about the
history of the AEC is that they
were both the promoters of the
technology and the developers of
the technology,
and they were supposed to be
the regulators.
So the fox watching the
henhouse, so to speak.
And this was recognized quite
early in the history of the AEC,
when Congress decided to break
off the responsibilities
associated with regulation to
have a higher probability of
safety and environmental
protection and worker safety.
So that the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission was given these
responsibilities.
So this is an independent
agency now that has
commissioners assigned to it
that make choices about issuing
licensing decisions and about
safety violations or
environmental violations
associated with the industry.
So that states have retained
authority over electric power
generation, sale,
and transmission.
Another aspect of the
development of the nuclear
industry which is important to
know is that this is not being
protected by private insurance
companies.
The Price Anderson Nuclear
Industries Indemnity Act really
holds the industry harmless from
damage claims in the event of a
serious accident.
And it also sets up a procedure
for compensation that has
criteria that are really pretty
clear,
that those that claim damage
have to show what it was,
they have to calculate their
monetary loss,
and they also have to
demonstrate causality that is
relatively easy to demonstrate
in this case because of a
specific isotope mixture
signature that would come from
any sort of a nuclear explosion
or an accident.
So the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission was created in 1974.
Now, you can imagine also that
many states might be more
worried about nuclear power than
other states.
And California is really a
pretty good example of that.
So that in 1976,
the State of California created
a moratorium on new nuclear
power plant construction.
So states might have the
authority to do that.
And until the federal
government approved of methods
to dispose of high level waste,
the State of California was
really quite concerned about
what the long-term costs might
be to manage that waste,
and also what the long-term
costs might be associated with
decommissioning the plant.
So the Pacific Gas and Electric
Company argued that the
Congressional intent to preempt
state regulation of the nuclear
industry was implicit in the
Atomic Energy Act.
So again, preemption is a
critical legal tool that the
industry relied upon in order to
claim that the State of
California did not have
authority to create this
moratorium.
So the Supreme Court eventually
ruled on this case,
and its finding is quite
interesting.
The federal government
possesses exclusive regulatory
authority over construction and
operation of nuclear facilities
and over radiological safety.
And the states hold authority
over decisions concerning the
need for additional generating
facilities, licensing,
ratemaking, land use,
and planning.
And the Supreme Court argued
that federal law would preempt
the moratorium if it was related
to safety concerns.
So that's an interesting idea.
The federal government would be
the experts in the area of risk
assessment and environmental
assessment.
Thank you, Emily Jack-Scott.
You seem to have been quite
successful, persuasive.
So that if it's related to
safety concerns,
the court argued that
California did not have the
authority to establish a
moratorium because it was
worried about health effects or
environmental dangers.
But it concluded that the
federal law would not preempt a
moratorium if California's logic
was based on economics.
So if they were worried about
cost considerations down the
road.
So a very interesting
distinction that allowed this
moratorium to be sustained.
California's assertion that the
legislature had enacted the
moratorium based upon economic
concerns was eventually
accepted.
The Nuclear Waste Policy Act of
1982 is important because most
nuclear waste had been and is
now being stored in or nearby
nuclear power plants.
So it's highly dispersed around
the country.
Think back on the U.S.
map that I showed you with the
different dots of the location
of the plants.
That's where the nuclear spent
fuel, the fuel rods,
that are highly radioactive,
are being stored.
Within Connecticut,
this would include the Haddam
Neck Nuclear Power Plant that's
now been closed that's about
twenty miles from Yale to the
east,
and it would also include the
three Millstone plants over in
Niantic.
So that under this statute,
the Department of Energy was
granted the authority to begin
to centralize a nuclear fuel
reprocessing and repository.
So basically,
just a storage facility where
this waste could be handled
until it might be reprocessed.
But they were unable to open
the facility,
and by an amendment,
the site at Yucca Mountain was
established by DOE to be the
single repository.
So you can imagine that if you
were the State of Nevada,
you probably would not be too
happy about that.
But if you were the State of
California,
Connecticut,
or any other state that had
nuclear power plants,
you'd be really happy about the
prospect of getting rid of the
waste that's sitting inside your
state boundary.
So this prompted a lot of
litigation.
Litigation on the part of
Nevada, that did not want the
repository to be located there.
And litigation on the part of
other states,
including the State of
Washington, most recently,
arguing that they wanted their
waste taken to this power plant
and that the Obama
administration did not have the
right to decide that this
storage facility should not
open.
When one thinks about the
location of either the plants or
the storage facilities,
you need to think carefully
about evacuation requirements.
So before the Three Mile Island
accident in Pennsylvania,
the emergency response plans by
nuclear power plants in the U.S.
were voluntary.
That's quite striking,
given what the Atomic Energy
Commission and the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission understood
about the potential for these
nuclides to move over long
distances,
being transported in the air.
Now, the plans have to cover a
ten-mile radius.
Now think about that.
Ten miles, would that be
sufficient?
Well, we're about twenty miles
from the nearest nuclear power
plant here.
But if you think about the
Indian Point Nuclear Power Plant
outside of New York City,
then you need to think about
the capacity to move tens of
millions of people away from a
zone that would likely be highly
contaminated in the event of a
meltdown or an explosion or a
serious fire,
such as existed at Three Mile
Island or at Chernobyl.
So the Indian Point facility
prompted Governor Pataki to
commission a report to evaluate
the evacuation plan,
and criticized the
communication between local
agencies,
the size of the area that would
be affected by release,
and the plan's premise is that
an orderly evacuation,
rather than mass panic,
would likely ensue.
It's kind of interesting,
because if you drive around
Connecticut within ten miles of
the nuclear power plants,
occasionally,
you'll see a sign on the side
of the road,
sometimes very rural roads,
that notify the public that
this is part of an evacuation
route in the event of a nuclear
accident.
So that the capacity to move
people away from a contaminated
zone,
to be able to predict how that
zone might vary given weather
patterns,
it really is quite limited.
Also, there was no
consideration of the probability
or likelihood of a terrorist
attack at these plants.
And this raised the possibility
that there ought to be aerial
surveillance,
that there ought to be planes
that are flying nearby these
nuclear power plants,
as there was shortly after the
9/11 terrorist attack in New
York.
So that the Commission reported
that "Any plant adjacent to
high population areas should
have different requirements than
plants otherwise situated
because protective actions are
more difficult and the
consequences of a failure or
delay are higher."
And the "planning problems
are more serious because of the
large population
concentrations."
So I'm going to jump ahead here.
The core problem associated
with waste is radioactive
half-life.
And the key concern is over
plutonium.
And there are 270 tons of
separated plutonium from
reprocessing of fuel rods around
the world that now are sitting
at sites and being stored.
And it has a half-life of
roughly 24,000 years.
So when engineers and safety
experts were thinking about the
problem posed by Yucca Mountain,
this is the mountain in Nevada
where the storage facility has
been partially constructed,
using about nine billion
dollars of taxpayers' money.
So that the problem really here
was how do you ensure the
integrity of a storage facility
for nearly a million years?
And they chose this site
because of its remoteness.
Poor Nevada.
Remember, Nevada was also the
site of the Atmospheric Weapons
Testing Facility,
the largest and most often used
in the U.S.
And they designed a machine
that would bore into the rock
and create a tunnel within which
either canisters would be stored
as dry fuel,
or they could be stored in
water.
So the fuel is highly
radioactive, and it's cooled in
pools of water or in these dry
casks.
And it's currently stored at
sixty-six sites in the U.S.
This is what one of the storage
facilities might look like.
And that honeycombed set of
boxes that you can barely see in
the bottom of the pool over
here, that's how they store the
fuel rods, side by side.
By the way, it also creates
radioactive water so that the
amount of liquid waste that is
contaminated is far larger in
volume than the amount of waste
that is either low level or high
level waste.
So it was also curious that if
you're projecting out a risk
management strategy over tens of
thousands or hundreds of
thousands of years,
you know what happens if
something occurs and society no
longer speaks a language that is
understood today?
What if some massive accident
occurred,
nuclear war or whatever it is,
that leads whatever society
exists that stumbles across this
plant to recognize it?
Kind of interesting.
In a way, it was a labeling
issue.
How do you communicate risk,
not using language,
but using symbols instead?
So the Department of Energy
commissioned anthropologists to
think about different forms of
symbolism.
And they went back and looked
at what symbols would best
convey the idea that there was
something extremely dangerous
nearby or to stay away.
And the symbolism that is
chosen is not represented here.
But the nuclear symbols that
you see in the upper right hand
side of this slide are those
that are commonly used by the
nuclear industry.
But you can imagine if you did
not know the culture today,
if you'd never seen any symbol
on the side of a truck,
for example,
sometimes trucks have some of
these symbols that you wouldn't
have any idea what this meant.
The symbols on the lower right
are symbols that are commonly
applied for industrial and
worker safety situations,
whereas the symbol on the left
is several hundred years old.
So that I mentioned a lawsuit.
This most recent lawsuit this
year, this spring,
by Washington State v.
The Department of Energy,
was designed to encourage the
federal government to keep the
Yucca Mountain Repository
viable.
"The Attorney General
McKenna made the right decision
to file his lawsuit today to
stop the Administration from
closing down Yucca
Mountain."
Now, another problem with
nuclear power is the potential
for proliferation of nuclear
weapons.
So one might think that we need
to think about an international
strategy to control the
distribution of nuclear fuel.
So processed nuclear fuel could
be further enriched to form a
weapon grade that could produce
nuclear weapons.
So the International Atomic
Energy Agency and several other
private organizations banded
together to encourage the
creation of a nuclear fuel bank
so that the G8 has been proposed
to constitute this bank and be
responsible for the
dissemination of nuclear fuel
and then for its recovery once
it's spent.
In this way,
they would have a collaborative
attempt to try to manage the
fuel.
Thinking also about the MIT
faculty's conclusions regarding
safety,
they ended their report saying
that parallel with improved
operations,
the safety record of the
nuclear industry has really been
quite remarkable in the last
twenty years.
And it plays-- the
"nuclear power industry
displays by far the highest
capacity factor among all
generation technologies,
providing now about twenty
percent of the U.S.
electrical supply."
So that the belief is that most
reactors,
particularly the latest
generation reactors,
have the capacity to operate
safely,
but that the probability of
bringing them online in a way
that would make a significant
difference in the world with
respect to effects of energy
consumption and climate change
is really quite limited.
So that with respect to the
enrichment problem,
for example,
uranium, when it's mined,
is approximately point seven
percent uranium-235,
but it needs to have that
increased to four to five
percent in order for it to be
useable as fuel in a nuclear
power plant,
compared to twenty percent that
it has to be for nuclear
devices.
The Three Mile Island example
in 1979 created quite a bit of
alarm in the United States,
and it was also a time when a
movie came out called The
China Syndrome that
dramatized the effects of a
nuclear accident in an urban
area.
And the nuclear facility at
Three Mile Island experienced
what was about a sixty percent
meltdown.
And like most major accidents,
whether or not it's the space
shuttle that blew up or the
Bhopal incident in India,
where it's estimated that more
than 100,000 people were killed
in a chemical plant explosion,
or in Chernobyl,
many people think about the
problem being assigned to and
caused by technical failure,
technology failure,
hardware failure.
When in fact,
it's almost always human
failure, human failure to
monitor equipment effectively.
And that was certainly the case
at Three Mile Island,
when workers mistook the need
to open a valve to allow cooling
water to go in and cool down the
fuel rods that were heating up.
So in Bhopal,
it was a problem of gauges.
With the space shuttle blowing
up,
it was a problem of
misrecognizing the heat shield
tiles that had fallen off,
and that were highly
temperature sensitive.
So that the shuttle took off
during temperature conditions
that some recognized made it
dangerous.
So the case history that is
most important I think for us to
think about,
which caused the greatest
amount of environmental damage
in history with respect to a
nuclear power plant occurred at
the Chernobyl plant in Pripyat,
then within the Soviet Union.
And this occurred in April of
1986 and occurred during a
yearly maintenance operation,
where they were pursuing a
gradual power reduction.
And they basically lost control
of their maintenance efforts.
And the control rods were
removed too quickly,
and then the power shot back
down too low,
and the water in the plant was
turned in an improper direction.
The workers were confused about
what to do.
The power surged 1,500 times
its safe level within five
seconds,
and a steel shield on the roof
of the building was blown into
the sky,
and the entire facility caught
fire for a period of several
weeks.
So four days later,
after the Soviet Union has
maintained their silence,
the government announced,
"An accident has occurred
at the Chernobyl Atomic Power
Station.
One of the nuclear reactors has
been damaged.
Measures are being taken to
eliminate the consequence of the
accident,
aid is being given to the
victims, and a government
commission has been
established."
So anyone who knows anything
about industrial accidents or
nuclear power plants would
recognize that being able to
warn the public immediately
after an accident was
exceptionally important.
The only nuclear event that
this could be compared to was
one at Windscale,
now known as Sellafield,
in the northern part of Great
Britain,
where in 1956,
there was a fire in the plant
and a significant amount of
radiation was released into the
air.
And the workers of the plant
went out and commandeered the
tractors and cars of farmers
that lived in the surrounding
area.
And the farmers were standing
in the field watching these
workers basically drive away in
a caravan as quickly as they
could so that they could reduce
their exposure.
Again, no government warning,
no attempts to evacuate the
area.
So that the failure to take
action soon after an accident
like this results in the
population being exposed at the
highest levels.
So the Soviets then disclosed
"a certain leak of
radioactive substances,"
and then finally told the
public that 200 people were
hospitalized,
but that the water and the air
in Kiev were safe.
They were reassuring the public
in fact,
at the same time that their air
force was seeding the clouds in
the area,
trying to induce rain so that
it could wash the radiation from
the sky before it reached the
Russian state and also to
protect the reservoir that is to
the north of Kiev.
So finally, President Gorbachev
in '86 came on the news one
evening and said,
"Good evening,
comrades.
All of you know that there's
been an incredible misfortune.
The accident at the Chernobyl
plant has painfully affected the
Soviet people and shocked the
international community,
and for the first time,
we confront the real force of
nuclear energy out of
control."
There are a variety of
different stories and lessons
here, but perhaps the one that
is most sad is the way that
workers were mistreated.
The effects of being exposed to
radiation in the absence of
protective gear was very well
known to the Atomic Energy
Commission and to the Soviet
scientific experts from their
experiences with nuclear
weapons.
But other than potassium iodide
pills and the normal kind of a
suit that a fireman might wear
as protective gear,
they were left helpless,
even though they were told to
go in and try to put out the
flames of the burning and
charring fuel rods.
So also, the Soviets and others
misunderstood the pattern of
distribution of the
radionuclides once they reached
the atmosphere.
So here you see April 26,
the white that you see in the
right hand side of the upper
left air photo here,
is demonstrating the direction
of the plume.
By April 28,
the plume had reached up over
Norway, Sweden,
and Finland.
By April 30,
you can tell that the plume was
being dispersed and being blown
back around northern Europe.
And eventually,
by May 6, it had scattered
itself pretty much all over
Europe, with a patchy kind of a
concentration.
And you remember the surprise
on the part of the Atomic Energy
Commission to the patchiness of
the fallout,
finding high levels of
strontium-90 in New York and
Connecticut when the cloud
intercepted a rainstorm.
And this affected a fallout
pattern that was really quite
similarly non-uniform in Europe.
And it took roughly about ten
days for this plume to make its
way all the way around the
world,
moving across China and then
the Pacific Ocean to reach the
United States,
when it became detectable in
the milk supplies in states such
as Utah and Arizona and
California.
So that the sensors that
existed at that point in time
were picking up contaminants
eventually distributed around
the United States and eventually
the rest of the world.
So as you look at this map,
you see a radiation deposition
gradient from lightest color to
darkest color.
And what's so striking about it
is that you see the patchiness
demonstrated here,
where you have a significant
deposition in Austria,
a significant deposition in
Finland and up in both Norway
and in Sweden.
And the distance,
by the way, is probably about
600 to 700 miles,
maybe about 800 miles,
from Chernobyl up to Northern
Europe.
So one thing that this did was
it created complete chaos in
European food markets.
So if it reached the ground,
it was getting into the food
supply.
Well, they realized that the
different nations all had
separate radiation standards.
So that they did not have a
uniform regulatory system to
protect against one nation
selling one commodity that had a
radiation level that might not
be accepted by another nation
that had a tougher standard.
Also, the detection process,
you can imagine that the
government was slow to go out
and try to figure out this
patchiness with precision.
And that had tremendous
implications for the period of
exposure by the population.
So here's a good example of the
distributional pattern as it was
being recognized by the Soviet
Union back in the late 1980s.
And as they tested more,
they found more.
So that this map was constantly
changing in response to more
rigorous testing.
So that the different zones
that you see here are designated
as confiscated areas,
permanent control areas,
period control areas,
and unregulated areas.
So that the darkest red are the
confiscated areas.
So that lands,
agricultural lands,
urban lands,
homes, residential communities,
commercial areas,
were literally confiscated so
that hundreds of thousands of
people were moved off of their
land because the soils,
the plants, as well as the
building materials,
and even the vehicles,
were contaminated.
Hundreds of thousands of
vehicles turned into hazardous
waste, almost within a matter of
days.
So what to do with this area?
What do you do with people that
you're going to pull out of
their homes?
Well, they had to build new
communities.
And in some instances,
they even built new communities
in areas that were contaminated
because they hadn't tested
carefully enough.
Kind of interesting,
because it should ring bells
with you with respect to the
Bikini Island history,
where the Bikinians were
allowed to move back into an
area that the government
supplied funds for constructing
new homes,
and then they went in and
tested that more carefully and
found that they had to move out.
So that the tension here is
that the government will want to
limit its own liability,
its own costs for evacuating or
for dealing with hazardous
waste,
or for rebuilding a community.
So it has very little incentive
to disclose with precision the
intensity of the concentrations.
So in this case,
the precision grew in response
to international pressure
because they were finding the
patchy highly contaminated areas
in many different European
communities.
And those different countries
wanted to have international
authority to take the Soviet
Union to court so that they
could be compensated for their
losses as well.
The construction workers that
were trying to put out the fire
and then deal with the
contaminated areas would drive
vehicles in whether they were
aircraft,
whether or not they were cars
or trucks such as this.
The workers eventually were
suited up in protective gear,
and they had to wash down the
vehicles as they left the site
to keep the vehicles from
tracking the radionuclides to
different parts of the affected
area.
I mentioned that agricultural
lands were obviously affected,
especially those within the red
zones on the map that you just
saw.
What do you do with
contaminated lands like this?
Well, you basically have to
scrape the surface off of it and
figure out how you're going to
bury the contaminated material.
So that think about this,
76,000 thousand square
kilometers of contaminated land.
And what about the forest lands?
What would happen to the timber
that were growing in the area?
Well, they also absorb the
radionuclides.
And many of those trees were
still standing.
And many people would cut down
the contaminated trees,
cut the timber,
saw it up, turn it into
building material,
and people would build their
houses of it.
There's a similar analogy to
the way that the uranium mines
created the fuel for the power
plants,
the way that those mines left
waste of uranium mine tailings.
So what did they do with that?
Well in some instances,
they used the mine tailings as
a construction material for
homes, particularly on Native
American reservations.
So there's a very unhappy and
costly history of how Navajos
were living in homes that were
built from cement products that
contained uranium.
So that the enormity of the
effect of the contamination was
just beyond anybody's
expectation.
Cars, trucks,
tanks had to be buried.
And there are many stories
about how cars would be buried
at night.
They'd be dug up before dawn,
and parts from those cars would
then be removed and sold on the
black market.
So you all know that there's a
very robust used car part market
virtually everywhere in the
world.
So that these radioactive used
parts were brought back,
recycled back into circulation.
In Sweden it's interesting.
Because the Swedes found out
about this,
not because they were notified
by the Soviets or any other
nation,
but because their workers
showed up at their nuclear power
plants and they started setting
off alarms.
So that power plants in Sweden
were shut down one after
another,
but not because there was a
problem at their plant,
but because their workers were
walking in the door to the plant
in the morning and they had
picked up the radionuclides that
had been deposited on the
streets or the sidewalks in
Sweden,
and that contamination had set
off the alarms.
That's when they started
looking at weather patterns and
trying to figure out what the
source might be.
There was no evidence that a
nuclear weapon had been
detonated,
so they started at the location
of nuclear power plants and were
able to piece together the
weather pattern over the past
several days to pinpoint the
Chernobyl plant.
So that within several days,
the radiation in Sweden was
1,000 times higher than it
previously had been.
So I'm going to jump ahead here
to a discussion about
evacuation.
Civil defense officials were
finally able to convince the
government and plant officials
of the need to evacuate areas
that were closest to the plant.
But thirty-six hours had passed.
And these are,
if you look at the current
charts about the periodicity of
the release of the radiation,
you find that this first
thirty-six hours was a crucial
period,
when that population should not
have been allowed to stay in the
area.
So that they really had no plan.
The government eventually was
able to put together 1,000 buses
and picked up first the children
and then moved them hundreds of
miles away to different camps.
So as they studied the pattern
of deposition,
they found that their
evacuation zone had been defined
too narrowly.
So the evacuation zone had to
be continually expanded.
So that by May 3,
this was only about six or
seven days later,
45,000 residents had been
evacuated from a ten-kilometer
radius.
Eventually, 210,000 people were
resettled into less contaminated
areas.
By the way, if you take the
United States' requirement that
every nuclear power plant in our
nation have an evacuation plan
that would cover an area that is
defined by a ten-mile radius and
you compare it to the movement
of contamination from this
plant,
you can see the ten-mile radius
in green here compared to the
eventual location of the deep
red colored confiscation zones
more than a hundred miles away.
So I'm going to jump ahead here
because I'm going to run out of
time.
The safety regulations varied
quite highly among the different
nations, leading to a chaotic
set of bans.
So that finally,
the Europeans decided to ban
meat, live animals,
and produce from all areas
within 1,000 kilometers of the
site.
The economic consequences were
enormous.
So that the Austrian government
banned the import of East Block
milk,
fruit and vegetables,
the Dutch Agricultural Ministry
prohibited cattle grazing.
The Swiss were warned against
providing fresh milk to young
children.
Italy banned the sale of its
own leafy vegetables.
And even the U.S.
was warning people not to go to
several European nations because
of the extent of the
contamination.
So the economic consequences
just associated with the food
supply and its contamination
were far higher than anybody
imagined.
There's also a sad story about
the Sami indigenous group in
northern Sweden that have long
relied upon the livestock of
reindeer.
And reindeer feed on moss and
lichen,
and the radionuclides built up
heavily in the moss and lichen
and were detectable in their
meat within a matter of several
days following the accident.
So that the Swedish government
decided that it was going to ban
the sale of all future products
from these animals except for
the sale of furs.
So to come to a conclusion
here, you'll be able to study
this slide not from this
lecture, but up on the Classes
server.
So that if you think about the
relative amount of radioactivity
that was released by the first
atomic bombs in curies,
you see the first atomic bombs
up here on the top at Nagasaki
and Hiroshima having released
about 250,000 curies from atomic
weapons testing totally.
During that period,
the atmospheric weapons
testing, those figures are given
here.
But then if you look down here
at Chernobyl,
you find that the estimates of
exposure and the estimates of
those exposed are really quite
amazing.
Seventeen thousand and four
hundred fatal cancers were
expected among 2.9 billion
people exposed.
So more than half of the
world's population was exposed
to fallout from this nuclear
power plant explosion,
with a very serious estimate of
fatal cancer outcomes.
Compared to the Atomic Weapons
Testing Program,
where among everybody at the
time--this report was done back
in the 1990s by the National
Cancer Institute--
everybody in the world was
anticipated to have been
exposed,
but only 12,000 fatal cancers
were expected from that entire
program.
So the magnitude of exposure,
the magnitude of risk,
is associated with this kind of
a failure, has long been
underestimated.
Now I'm going to leave you at
this time with one other
thought,
because I opened the lecture
saying that we're facing a very
difficult decision on how to
allocate our resources and
investments in different kinds
of fuels.
And I want you to think too
about the relative risks
associated with coal-fired power
plants.
We don't have too much time to
talk about coal.
But coal produces not just
sulfur and nitrogen oxides,
it produces particulates.
And particulates,
particularly in combination--
particulates,
particularly,
sorry.
Particulates in combination
with the sulfates pose a very
serious health threat.
And many people don't realize
that between 20,000 and 60,000
premature deaths in the United
States alone every year are now
attributable to coal-fired power
plants.
On a world scale,
the number is far more
significant.
So these are deaths that are
premature deaths,
particularly among those that
have background conditions of
cardiovascular illness or other
kinds of respiratory illnesses.
So that premature deaths from
this form of energy are far
higher than have ever been
accounted for with respect to
the nuclear industry.
So that coal has this image of
being a relatively safe fuel
compared to nuclear power.
But I'm hoping to get you to
rethink that.
The nuclear waste issue I think
is overwhelmingly persuasive to
me that the nuclear industry
should not be seriously
encouraged.
And I am disappointed and
surprised by the Obama
Administration's support that
came out just a few weeks ago
for it.
And next Tuesday,
we'll be talking about the
future of renewables,
and particularly,
the different kinds of legal
strategies that have been
employed,
including tax strategies,
different subsidies,
different kind of credit
systems, in order to try to
increase human investment in
renewable sources.
So have a great weekend and
enjoy the weather.